this is kind of cool but you have to be
careful with that once when you're
holding a hammer everything looks like a
nail
so you're like I can I can multiply all
these numbers together let's think about
something like this now these are two
numbers in index form and you know I've
just worked out oh cool when you've got
these things with indices I just add the
indices together okay
now before I jump to your answer I'm
gonna get to version I'm gonna get you
to suggest in a second but for the sake
of the pattern that we've just
established right what does this
actually mean well 2 cubed is 2 times 2
times 2 okay and then you've got this
guy 5 times 5 times 5 times 5 ok
excellent right now up here I said how
many threes are there and then up here I
said how many 7s are there now when you
have a look at this what's going to
happen first you had your hand up before
what could we possibly do with this
there's three of them there yeah yeah ok
now what you've noticed is you're like
oh how many twos are there in total
there are the three that I started with
right how many fives are there in total
there are the four that I started with
right so you can see you like oh I can't
there's no way to collapse this right
Mac what are you thinking ah now here's
a really interesting question it's so
interesting I'm going to repeat it for
everyone because I want to think about
it right we've got 2 & 5 and we're
multiplying right can I just say well 2
times 5 is 10 and then I'll add the
powers like I did before now let's just
think about this for a second ok the
first thing I want to point out is how
do we do it before like see how I've got
7 times 7 here did I end up with 49 to
the power of 6 I didn't because I looked
at what it actually meant and it's like
oh I've just got a lot of sevens this is
how many sevens I've got right is this
make sense so in this example mr. Keeble
I did not multiply the what is this
thing on the bottom cord it's called the
the base the base just stays the same
right so then when I look over here
should I multiply the basis no I
shouldn't and the other way we can
confirm for this all right before I said
all you could get your calculator out
and check if you wanted please get your
calculator out now okay I don't actually
know what 2 cubed times 5 to the power
of 4 is okay okay 5 what did you say
what 5,000 and that makes sense that's 8
times 0 25 perfect okay now that's what
I get from left what are you thinking ok
so this is exactly where we're coming to
you I'm going to park that thought for a
second and return to it as soon as we
establish what's going on on this
left-hand side can you confirm for me
we've got one suggestion that it's 5,000
the left-hand side keep popping into
your calculator press the index button
put in the 3-pin the 4 do you get 5,000
as well we on the right track
yep okay wonderful now this guy here
right this is not 5,000 is it what is it
it's 10 million you're like hold on it's
one with seven zeroes after it okay
these last I checked 5,000 was not 10
million okay so in fact it seems like
and this is one of these you can always
do like is this true is this gonna work
out would give it a go
you have tools at your disposal to give
this a try right it turns out that the
simplest way to write this is just kind
of where we started right so if you have
another color like red or green or
something like that right what I'd love
you to write is different bases
different bases that's what the two and
the five are right different bases don't
mix if you want to think about this like
what we learned last you'd remember with
fractions remember fractions if I gave
you say R 1/2 plus 1/3 right you you
can't just mix them together you
actually have to do things to those yeah
you've got to muck about with them
before they can talk you would convert
them into sixths right so different
bases don't mix unless you can get them
to talk to each other and I'm gonna give
you one real quick example of what that
looks like before I then let you have a
go at some exercise so here's the last
example we're going to have a quick look
at let's do
I actually had one written down yep
let's do this okay now I just went and
wrote down it's probably so did you
I just went wrote down different bases
don't mix well they usually don't mix
but sometimes and we'll look at the
sometimes they can so let's have a look
at this and unpack it just like we did
before two cubed is still 2 times 2
times 2 just like from the previous line
what's 4 cubed 4 times 4 times 4 but
this is kind of interesting here because
see these fours you know how we did the
prime factorization prime factorization
120 right you can break these down
further because 4 is not prime right
twos prime 3 is prime 7s prime did you
notice that okay but 4 is not so I'm
going to rewrite this 4 times 4 times 4
in this way just put your pens down for
a minute and look up so that you've
watched this part okay see this first 4
here I'm gonna rewrite it as 2 times 2
do you get that that's what 4 is yeah
and then I'm gonna look at the next 4
and I'm gonna say that is also 2 times 2
and then I'm gonna do this one last time
because I've got 1 2 3 times here
there's the last one so there's a 4
there's a 4 there's a 4 okay I know
there's a lot of them but how many twos
do you count Russian have you got nice
fantastic we want to get some agreement
on this so I'm happy so I can write this
as 2 to the power of 9 okay where we got
this from by the way is that this is 2
cubed
whoops times how many twos are here in
red just the red ones that's six of them
there are three pairs which gives you 6
right so that's actually to the power of
6 and you can see I'm doing just what I
did before right look at these guys 3 &
6 you add them and you get 9 fantastic
ok so we can summarize all of this right
this is all examples with numbers but we
can write a single line which catches
everything
the thing on the board any number that
you'd like okay so we would say in
summary can you guys read at the bottom
sorry it's a bit low I didn't mean to
get this low on the board if you have
any number write any number and it's
raised to some power like that you know
like seven there's any number and you
raise it to some power like two so long
as you multiply it by a number with the
same base see that see these guys are
the bases and they're the same right if
there's some other power what happened
what did we do with this - and the four
the three the two the one of the five
what do we do to those powers we we
added them so I'm multiplying here and
the new power is going to be what
happens when you add the powers right M
plus n so let me say it like this okay
when you multiply numbers are the same
base you're going to add the indices
okay multiplication over here means
adding the indices